Hey, you want to know about that?
One of my proudest moments of being a dad yeah. Happened this morning. Yeah.
So you know how a a meal is a little bit of an introvert, right?
When we sort of worry whether he socializes enough, well,
we were taking him to daycare and uh, we're getting,
he's taken his shoes off and there's this little boy who's only there two days a
week and he's not adjusting well. And every time his mother drops him off,
she has to literally pry him off her and he's wailing and you know,
so a meal sits down on this little seat to take his shoes off.
The mother of this kid puts this little boy next to a meal and he is just
crying. He's distraught.
So then what happens is a meal turns to this little boy looks at him,
sticks out his hand and says high five.
I don't know where that is. Amazing. Yeah. Because it's like they're,
they're out in their own society, you know, especially, yeah.
Okay. So let's do the introductions. Um, I'm Jan. Hi, I'm Robert.
This is radio lab. We're calling this show patient zero. Yeah.
And for this next segment, no more patients, no more diseases. We exactly.
Let's focus instead on invention on the people who bring new ideas into the
world. Yeah. The zeroes behind the ideas. That doesn't quite sound right.
You know what I mean? Yeah. And that guy you just heard,
hi, my name is John McClellan.
I'm a contributing writer at the New York Times magazine.
He's got his own high five story to tell though. It's not about his daughter.
We have, I think we have kids around the same age as her first high five.
It's actually about the first high five ever. Yeah.
Ever. Yeah. Seat. One morning, a few years ago,
2007 or 2008 John turned on his computer, opened up his email and found
a press release about the true undisputed inventor at the high five coming,
you know, out final, who has the press release from national high five day,
which is a kind of a joke holiday that was invented by a group of high school
friends, I think. And they told the story. They told the story of Lamont sleep.
So
College Basketball Player, Murray State in Kentucky,
the story in the press release with something like this, sweets,
his father fought in Vietnam as part of, uh, the first battalion 50
infantry, which was nicknamed the five.
And they used to greet each other by holding up their hand and saying five as a
kind of prideful. And when Lamont was younger,
they would all sort of hang out at the House and Kentucky and he couldn't keep
all their names straight. So when they'd walk in the door and he'd go five,
he would just sort of smack their hand.
They go high five, oh, like hi, like hello five hello five high comma, five.
You know, he has small hands,
he likes to put them up against the big hands of the five guys.
And it was years later that he started playing college basketball at Murray
state and started high fiving all his teammates. He didn't really,
never stopped high-fiving, it was just something he did.
But when he went around playing away games,
other teams picked it up and it sort of spread out.
So he was sort of both the inventor of the high five and the kind of Johnny
Appleseed of the high five
at the same time. And within a few weeks of John Getting this press release,
the story was everywhere when kind of
viral. It wound up sort of all over the internet.
There were some local newspapers who, you know, picked it up, you know,
Murray states, and they became very proud of the fact that they were the,
the home with a high five.
It became sort of part of the institutional lore in the athletic department
there. And then you read this and you thought, what? Uh, I thought, uh,
how sad
[inaudible]
how sad. How Sad. Because I knew the story of Glenn Burke.
Turns out John had already been poking around into this question of who invented
the high five and he'd stumbled on this photograph. You know what?
Maybe I don't have it, but a black and white picture. Oh yeah.
Here we go to baseball players facing each other. Afros,
huge smiles and their hands are in the air, right about to connect.
Which one of these is Glenn Burke? So Burke's Burke's,
the guy in the warm up jacket, I think he's even got his hat on backwards.
Glenn Burke was a center fielder for the La Dodgers in the 70s. Big Guy.
He says he had 17 inch biceps. So I'll take, I'll take his word for that.
The other guy in the picture is a dusty Baker. He's an outfielder.
But you can tell in the picture just from the way that Glen is sort of throwing
his whole body forward that he's the one initiating the gesture.
I mean this is a guy who was, um, you know, the soul of the Dodgers clubhouse.
They just had that type of um, charisma. This is Luther Burke Davis.
Glenn sister with Glenna was like, like he'd always be on a stage,
often said he should have been a comedian. He was always dancing around in the,
in the club as he,
he used to do a Richard Pryor stand up routines just from memory.
You just genuinely love people so much though.
She says that in the year that picture was taken, the Dodgers made him the,
they sort of public face of the team. He was their ambassador of goodwill.
He's the guy. They'd say that to all the press events. Know,
like meet the youngsters on plots and stuff.
Here's the story about this picture. What was the date?
October 5th politically enough, 1977 to playoffs,
Dodgers versus Phillies game four bases are loaded.
Dusty Baker steps to the plate and [inaudible]
grand slam crowd goes nuts.
Baker does his victory lap and just disease around in 30 come into the plate.
Bear comes racing out of the dug out and he's got his arm really high up in
Baker season. Him instinctively raises his arm and before you know it,
Burke and Baker,
smack hands, Bam. There it was the sportscasters that would, you know,
announcing the game,
said they had never seen that done in sports before and from there on the
Dodgers started high fiving and everyone else started high-fiving and the high
five became a thing [inaudible]
[inaudible]
and it all began with that one moment.
Platonic high five right there.
Unfortunately that moment,
that was actually both the beginning and also almost the end of Burke's career.
It's not that he wasn't good. He was actually really good.
Even in his rookie season,
he was being talked about as the next Billy nays by the Dodgers organization.
But, uh, he was gay
and he tried to keep that a while he was playing a dusty baker actually had kept
trying to set him up with his wife's cousins. And a Burke never won.
You never liked any of them. And Baker's completely confused cause he knew,
you know, these were, these were really good looking women apparently.
So there were rumors circulating and the rumors reached the front office of,
of the La Dodgers. And,
and one day Burke was called in by management and they offered him $75,000 to
get married. It's 75,000 to get married. Huh?
What is this like the mob or something? Well exactly. I mean, no,
they didn't regularly offer their players money to get to get married. And,
and Burke's response apparently was, uh, he said, I suppose you mean to a woman?
Shortly after that the Dodgers traded into the Oakland days for a player who
everyone acknowledged was completely inferior.
That was confusing for us and I know had to be confusing for him.
It was shocking. And everyone, no one understood why he was traded.
And you think it was because he was gay. Yeah.
You know, baseball, this all American sport. Yeah. But you know,
at least he was still going to be able to play ball, or at least he thought
he ends up in Oakland, doesn't get very much playing time.
And when he did get on the field,
it wasn't very pleasant. He used to get heckled a lot, you know,
from people in the bleachers. And, and even worse,
according to a couple of different people,
his coach Billy Martin would often introduce Glenn Burke this way.
This is Glenn Burke, the Faggot Greeley. Yeah.
And uh, so Glenn Burke retires. Wow. And he was only like 26 or something,
right? Yes. He was young within a year of his rookie season just walks away.
God, that's like a onboarded career. Exactly. From there,
he ends up in the Castro district in San Francisco,
which is the big gay neighborhood and things go, yeah.
Okay. For Awhile. But then one day when he's crossing the street,
three teenage girls in their mother's car come barreling down the road and um,
they hit him and broke his leg in three places and that kind of ended
everything. When that happened,
he starts taking painkillers. One thing leads to another,
he gets hooked on crack, can't hold a job, he goes broke,
ends up living on the street. And uh, in 1994, Burke,
uh, is diagnosed with, with HIV or aids, I guess aids at that point.
And he ended up coming to live with me
[inaudible]
lot of times he didn't sleep well at night and we would sit up and talk,
put on music and I dance and he move his arms around cause he was in the bed,
he was bedridden.
[inaudible]
and so you took care of him until he died? Yeah.
Glenn Burke died in 1995.
[inaudible]
but what he's left with out at this point is he's left with the original five,
right? That's his claim. Yes. Yes.
That defined him to some people at least at the end. And He, and he believed it.
A reporter had asked him, you know, if it was true about the high five.
And he said, yeah,
think about the feeling you get when you give someone the high five.
I had that feeling before everybody else. Huh?
So what did you do when you got this press release?
So I called national high five day because I wanted to talk to Lamont sleets
even though I was sad. Uh, it seemed like, okay,
here's another person's prideful accomplishment. Um, let's get his story. Hello.
Hello. Eventually. Hey, there we go. He gets this guy on the phone.
Uh, my name is Greg Carroll Ledge.
Greg is one of the founders and he and John Get to talking and John Asks Him,
yeah,
the sensible first question is the Lamont sleet story. True. He figured it was,
but you know, he thought he should at least ask.
He said a reporter and there was a pause and he said, no.
Frankly, we've been waiting for someone to ask.
We thought no one would ever ask. It's not true.
It's just something that we had made up.
We've learned to see if the media would, would run with it.
They made the whole thing.
They made the whole thing up and then they just went to go cast their
protagonists. So we sat down,
we picked a Murray state that's just kind of a great sounding school at pops up
in the NCAA tournament every few years.
And they came across this Guy Lamont sleets. Why him? They,
well it was pretty close to random.
They then told me they had received an email from Lamont's leads his wife.
Absolutely.
His wife emailed us and said some of the details that you have or are flat out
wrong. That implies that some of the things you've said are right though.
But Lamont things he probably did invent the high five. Wait, wait, wait, wait.
What about Glenn? I was Kinda like
Kinda a bit blown away, you know? Yeah. You know,
here was this guy who is proud of this and these guys.
It just kind of stripped it away from him. Do you feel a little guilty?
Did I mean like, okay, it's a high five. It's kind of a silly thing.
On the other hand, this guy's life, the way he died,
do you feel like you robbed him? We do feel, uh, we do feel,
we wished that we had done things slightly differently and,
and putting together this sort of, uh, collegiate prank,
but we didn't really know of Glenn Burke at that time.
Greg says they hadn't heard of the Glenn Burke story when they pulled this
prank. And now that they know it, they really feel bad. Both Derek, in fact,
they're now organizing a charity event.
They're calling the national high five Athon,
which will raise money for charity,
including one chosen by Glenn Burke's sister Luther. Very proud.
Anytime I see somebody do a high five, it just really makes me happy.
And that seemed like a good end to the story. But, uh, no,
because then John told us that if you really honestly want to get to the bottom
of who invented the high five, I mean, we didn't think we wanted to,
but now that we're in it, what the hell? Well,
you've got to go beyond Glenn Burke Story.
I've wanted you to believe that he was the hero.
So maybe I should tell you a little bit about Derek Smith, right?
Even though Glenn Burke died believing that the high five was his legacy at more
or less the same moment that he invented it. A guy named Derek Smith,
a basketball player for the Louisville,
Cargill was that practice and a guy named Wiley Brown went up to Derek Smith and
was going to give him just a ordinary low five and Derek Smith looked him in the
eye. This is what Wiley Brown told me.
Derek Smith looked him in the eye and said, no, up high
that year, his Louisville team, they were,
they were known as the doctors of dunk. You know they're high flying team.
They played above the rim and John Says,
when Louisville played in the 1980 NCAA finals, I haven't seen it,
but apparently the broadcasts are referred actually to the high five handshake,
give them a high five high five.
He felt compelled to explain it to America and it did at the moment that Derek
Smith did it, did an asteroid fall on his head or something? Well
in 1996 I believe in in the 90s he had an undiagnosed heart condition and he
just died all of a sudden on a, on a cruise ship. What? Yes.
And um, he said explicitly the Wiley Brown,
this is something I'm going to be remembered for. You know,
our kids and our grandkids are going to talk about this and in fact their kids
in grant's kids do talk about it
and they're probably very proud.
But it was Kathy then we ran into this woman, you'll love fireworks.
This is Kathy Gregory.
She coached women's volleyball in the 1960s years before Glenn Burke and Derek
Smith. And she says with her girls,
everyone did it all the time.
So I do believe that it was volleyball at first started it.
And interestingly she says they would high five more when a player screwed up.
Yes. No, no. It isn't just about celebration.
Cause really when do you need a high five? Of course it's more when your doubt.
Yeah, it makes people so happy.
So women's volleyball, there you go. In Obama, Malcolm d no, snip out.
You need because then I produce it. The Levy also discovered that in the movie,
breathless in 1955 and exactly one hour,
18 minutes into the filming,
we'll see two Frenchmen do a very distinct boot to sank at eight 30 Amigo right
there.
[inaudible]
isn't this all like an indication to you that did it?
It's maybe it's one of those things that probably was there that Donald man
because it like gives pleasure. Yeah.
It's just like from an evolutionary point of view. No, I don't think so.
I think, I think it's a,
I think this has the feeling of something that was born. Yeah.
We have to decide like we have to confess like who in this room wants the gay
guy to be the, the, the inventor I want to get. Yeah, I'll raise my hand. Sure.
Yeah. It's the better story of the two and something in me says like, just go,
go with the narrative winner. You know, so I, you don't,
you don't even have the narrative winter. What are you doing here?
We didn't you, I was bored at my desk. This is pat.
Walter is our producer.
You guys clearly failed at finding the first high five and you're saying you
have the best. Yeah. There's no such thing as the best there is.
I'm about to tell you what it is. We've already done.
We've already beating the dead horse here. All right, good. What is it?
What is hello? Hi features, this guy named Tim [inaudible]. This is him. Yup.
And that's his girlfriend, Katie, Haiti.
And this little mini story begins in 2004 when July evening,
beautiful light out. Tim's out riding his motorcycle up.
10 minutes into my ride, the deer jumped out
in front of me and uh,
he slammed on his brakes and his bike
of like skidded and there was a mailbox just snapped my neck.
I woke up, I was laying in the hospital room and uh, opened up my eyes.
I went to lift my arm up cause I'm itchy nose. Yeah. And my arm wouldn't move.
He's paralyzed from the neck down. And so for seven years,
Tim hasn't been able to hug his daughter or for that matter, his girlfriend.
Yeah, we started the date they, after my accident,
I've never been able to hold her hand or reach out and touch me. I mean,
I feel that I'm almost in a prison,
but fast forward a few years,
Tim signs up for an experimental procedure at the University of Pittsburgh.
Doctors open his skull connect wires for the part of his brain that would move
his arm if his arm worked in the connect the wires to a robot arm.
Dave even Katie said or whatever,
whenever she saw the wires coming out like that. So that's what's a weird,
crazy.
And there's a video of one of the first times that Tim actually moves this arm.
What you see is him sitting in a chair,
doctor's kind of watching and his girlfriend Katie is just in front of him off
to the left a little bit.
They hooked me up to the alarm and um, the machine said, Huh. Huh?
Tim kind of grimaces
yeah, my brain was sending out that specific type of signal, let me up. Yeah.
And once the computer was able to read that,
the arm started to go up in the air. Alright.
Not long after this moment.
Katie stands up from the chair that she was sitting in the side,
Tim and walks over in front of the arm
and uh, it without even talking, she held out her hand
and she says,
okay,
for a moment there's this like stillness in the room
and then the robot arm jerks forward just like a fraction of an inch.
Katie's hand holding up there. That was the target. The touched her hand.
Then the arm jerks up a little bit more.
You can see him going from looking at the alarm
and then a little bit more.
So looking at me and then looking at the arm
a little bit more
until
they're touching.
When I looked at him like
I just started tearing up and then he started tearing up
sales
and in a way, this high five, if you can call it that,
it was sorta like the first time they ever touched
space and time.
I was able to put the piece of machinery that looked very similar to a hand on
her head. Not only did I just caught her,
pushed into her hand
[inaudible]
it was weird too because the hand was actually warm.
The hand was warm.
Yeah. Like that's one thing that I just kept saying to people like it was warm.
It wasn't cold.
[inaudible]
I don't know. It's just,
it's still kind of like boggled my lines when I think about it.
[inaudible]
we should say thank you to Pat Walters. Yeah.
Did Dad was kind of not bad that Walter's not bad. Not Bad,
but let's remember where after the first twins, right. Your best.
We're looking for the first and we're going to take one big leap before we
finish the show and to try something really odd. Hi, how are you doing? Oh,
we met the guy. Um, I'm Johnny Hughes.
I'm a documentary maker from Britain. I'm also a science journalist.
He's an author.
He recently wrote a book called on the origin of tps and it's about peace.
Why as well, if I'm being honest,
it was because it was a sort of pun on the origin of species and nothing was
wrong as a species. But you see,
Johnny wanted to write a book about the origins of ideas,
the same way that Darwin wrote his book about the origin of species.
So I went chasing off after tps, which brought him to the USA,
and then he ended up driving across the country straight across
[inaudible]
going west into the, onto the great plains as he did the,
the farm's gateway to prairie and then two wide open fields.
That was at that point did he noticed something a little different?
There was a distinct change in headgear. Yeah.
As soon as you get onto the short grass prairie, right after Bismarck,
there's a very obvious transition from baseball caps to carb
[inaudible].
Matt got him to wondering like, how did the cowboy hat get to the west?
Suddenly there it is and he's thinking who designed it or created it or invented
it and he's decided to do some research.
And at first the answers seemed pretty obvious and actually quite simple.
So here's his explanation. Number one. So the answer wanted the question,
who invented the cowboy hat? It's straightforward and it goes like this.
1865 the gold rush. Colorado.
Everyone's coming in from all over the world to make their fortune,
pay him for gold. They bring their heads.
So there's a sort of mixture of hats from all different parts of the world,
from an autonomous house for the city's quite a ridiculous collection of hats.
We might say you've got silk top hats.
No seriously in collar in the gold rush. In the gold rush.
That would be your Abe Lincoln hat. Great. In the east coast cities.
Pretty useless on the top of Pike's peak. Why?
Cause it's cause it gets blown off by the wind blown off. It gets wet.
So you've got your a but you also have raccoon skin has the sort of Davy
Crockett things great in the winter.
But in the summer they got full of flannels and they made you really hot as
well. That's not good.
You also had straw hats from the plantations from the south. We care.
I don't know, kind of flimsy. That would would've been some. Some burrows.
Not Bad actually. Yeah. Keep the sun off your eyes, keep your cool.
But they have enormous brims. A problem is when it rains,
water just collects and stays on.
There you are in Colorado with lots and lots of hats,
but none of them were perfect. All of them was slightly unfit.
Inter Mr John B Stetson,
he was the son of a hatmaker in the east coast and he came over looking for his
fortune and the story goes when he landed in Colorado,
he looked around and he immediately sought no opportunity.
Went back to the east coast,
gathered his thoughts and in a moment of unnatural and inspired inspiration,
if you can be so inspired. He saw the fully formed cowboy hat in his head.
Yeah. So he had the model in his head and what was it?
I said his model was it needed to have a wide brim to keep the sun and the rain
off your head, but not as wide as Edinburgh cause that was impractical,
but also much wider. The say a top hat,
which was useless and needed to be waterproof because he knew that it was wet
over in the west, needed to have a high dome on top to keep you cool up there.
He knew what it ought to be.
So after a little hammering and stretching and cutting,
he had the perfect hat and he called it the boss of the plane,
which everyone in the west wanted to be. So Peter the scene boss,
the planes arrives, it's gorgeous. You want one,
you throw away your horrible raccoon thing and you went from one of those.
It very quickly became a status symbol.
That is story number one. Pretty straight forward. Yeah. It was a guy,
it's a guy. It's JB stats and he came up with the idea. He was a genius.
He got it sold. What's the problem with that story?
The problem with that says Johnny and he realized that the moment he landed out
west and he started to look into this [inaudible] close your eyes and imagine
you know your your quintessential cowboy hat. You asked me to do this,
please just do it. Okay, got it. My head, is it a high dome? Get broad brim.
Very, it's got a dent in the tub. We'll see.
The picture that we have in our heads is not what Stetson invented. Really? Why?
I mean, what did stetsons look like?
Probably the Dallas cowboy hat you could possibly imagine, you know,
rolling up the edge of the brim. No dense on the crown. Uh,
had a little ribbon around it. Um, ribbon. Yeah, it's not very bossy.
That's dainty. So Johnny did some more research and he now comes up,
this is coming up now.
Theory number two to explain who or what designed the hat.
Again, 1865, it's Colorado gold rush time. People are coming in from all over.
J B Stetson shows up. He makes the hat,
the hat was very expensive. You couldn't afford more than one. So from then on,
for the next 10 years,
you would wear it like all the time you'd be picking up the whole time with the
crown.
So you'd be pushing these dents into it every time you sort of jihad and you'd
also be sleeping on your hands. He'd be folding over the brim.
So within a few years, the cowboy heroes,
these guys are turning up at the railhead towns with these,
what we might call in Britain, knack head boss of the planes, hats.
That looked like a completely different happened.
The one they bought in the store. Yeah, that'd be battered. And you know,
think about this.
If you're a a young cowboy and you're looking for your first cowboy hat,
do you want one that looks like the guy who runs the hardware shop,
who's got the pretty dainty one or do you want the one with a dent like your
dad, the cowboy.
And so hat makers picked up on this and they began producing pre dented,
crumbled, knackered hats, Stetson responded as well.
You can look through the kind of order books of stats and you will see the
designs change over time.
All of which is to say if you want to tell the story this wet so you can say yes
that soon was there. Stetson played his part.
But when it comes to a true cowboy hat,
the one we think of when we think of a hat that's in really didn't invent it,
the cowboys did
[inaudible].
The entire population of cowboys were instrumental in choosing the future
evolution of the cowboy hat. It's almost like the market's deciding,
which in this case is cowboys. And, and can I just plant my flag and say,
that seems like a very sensible theory. It does. But, um,
something about this story number two was still nagging Johnny. Oh,
there's more, he's gonna go one more round. They want to come with him.
I will go. Here we go. The third answer to the question,
who invented the cowboy hat is no one did.
Well, someone did.
What I mean is that there were no mindful decisions going on here.
Not even a community of people mindfully chose where the cowboy hat was going to
go mindfully. Yeah. So, um,
what do you suppose he means by mindfully?
This is where you get a little bit of science. You know that if you were,
say a mouse and you were living in an environment happily,
and then all of a sudden things turn coal. If you have short hair,
you're going to shiver and then maybe die. Right? But if [inaudible]
another mouse happens to have longer hair, you know, they're going to do better.
They're going to do better in life. They're going to have more baby mice,
so overtime in this community you're going to get more and more and more mice
with longer and longer hair. Make sense? Now these mice,
they don't choose the length of their hair.
They just have the hair they got it is the weather.
It is the local environment.
That's what really shapes these mice and you could think of the hat in the same
way.
We're looking at the hat shape itself.
The hat shape is changing over time without any forethought.
Thanks to that gold rush.
In the 1860s you got a whole bunch of very different hats showing up on the
great plane and all those hats show up on heads and those heads and hats are
going to have horribly cold winters. Searingly hot summers,
they're going to be in the wind.
They're going to be out of doors because the main occupation is going to be
moving cattle across the plains in this very competitive hat situation,
the habits going to survive is the hat that you comfortable,
keeps you cool, keeps you dry. In other words, the cowboy hat.
Therefore, in this third version of our story, it wasn't Mr Stetson,
it wasn't the cowboys. According to Johnny, the environment created the hat,
the wind created the hat, the rain,
the sun, the snow,
the weather created those absolutely right.
This hat was just bound to appear in that place. In that time
it would have been invented by someone cause the habitat was there.
The environment was right.
There's something kind of poetic about the idea that the happens called the boss
of the plains and if your third movie is correct and it's really the plains
where the boss of the hat or something else Chad, that's brilliant.
I love that one. C On the other hand, I'm not sure I like it because
I'm just thinking about all the edits that we do as storytellers.
Like for the pieces in the show,
like nothing we're always trying to do is kind of get to moments and we're
trying to always atomize everything,
get down to the particular person who made the particular decision that resulted
in the particular change. Like that's what we want as storytellers.
So in some sense your scenario three is like the death of story.
In some sense it's the anti story. It feels less glamorous, doesn't it?
It runs to know,
do you know what? When Darwin came up with the theory of, well,
when he published his theory of evolution by natural selection,
that felt like a death in a way because it felt like you were taking away the
creator, this amazing being a,
you were diminishing life to sort of mindless process.
So a lot of people criticize him, criticized him for the same thing.
It's not as romantic, it's not as well. It is is awesome.
It's just not in the same way. Yeah.
And come to think of it, we always end up screwing up our stories, but you know,
you start to ask questions and then all of a sudden you're sucked into this
thing.
Suddenly it's called complicated and you have to deal with it and have to deal
with the everything that's of everything's, let's just keep it simple.
What is it about time Chad and Robert came into a show and said,
that's the end of it. And you know what? It was?
No. See, it's always more complicated. That is true. Yeah. I mean,
it's never really the end. Let me think about it. If what does an end,
you get the funding. Charlotte gets a credit, all these things [inaudible].